so brian we showed this to our viewers  at the start of the broadcast here this  train of starlight satellites from  spacex seen all over the valley tonight  really any way you kind of look at it  seeing something like this is pretty  exciting  in the backyard with the family we were  just relaxing and then we looked up into  the sky  and the lights appeared it was a big  straight line  uh and then the you know from the sky it  looked like they're probably about an  inch apart it was just  what seemed like maybe 20 30 likes i  don't know what we know but i know what  i saw  i can tell you that get george knapp on  the phone according to the tracking  website  the train will be visible again over las  vegas at 4 50  a.m the website to track it is on our  website at 8newsnow.com  also worth mentioning rick who you just  heard from there works for ccsd wanted  to give a special shout out to all the  teachers  for teacher appreciation week they work  very hard  day in and day out